was alive he will not keep one
isi
alive you just
said you you
be you just said you sent money to
America to kill Saddam Hussein what you
just said is that you support the idea
that s husse said to kill all the
Jews but you just said that you want all
Jews to die Jew that's what you just
said he
said said all
is now
beauti no don't try to use he a child
I'm not trying to be no no no no wait
don't try what he's saying he's not
talking about every Yi every Jewish
noing about talk about the state of
figh notus
said now if you want I'm not I'm not
going to challenge I'm not going to
challenge anybody on you said this if
you said that's not what I meant I'm
more than happy to say fine I'm more
than happy to say I'm not talking I'm
not talking please please I'm not
talking someone okay so whatever you say
if you want to go back I'm not even
going to challenge you I'm not going to
do but you said so I'm not no I'm not
going to do that but but if you if your
premise right now is that you support
any of the big terrorist leaders like s
Hussein wa wait wait
wait I do not support no murder the
question is
mid is terrorist respect
resp youut me off talking someone you
don't have to all these people here are
being very respectful and listening to
one person that's not is the one with
seven
C answer the question ask a question
the question I would appreciate if I
would be able to say my question my
chall my challenge my challenge was that
if you attack but if you would attack if
you were to support someone like Salam
Hussein yeah who did want to kill all
the Jews who did want to go and kill
every Israeli even if you don't Jews who
didly lie and several terrorist
attacks do something like do something
like like like any of any terrorist that
would do something like like like like
911 and then you don't and you say well
that's a good thing then I will
challenge you on that if you if that's
not what the argument you're making I'm
would than happy to back out I'm not
doing this camera you I'm not doing this
camera turn cam you
support what you about killing children
what do you about killing children okay
um before I go to this do you understand
what I said you keep running away from
me having conversation because I'm not
doing this I'm not doing this you supp
kill children dud I told you I'm not do
you suppos killing children Muslims no
we don't you suppos kill children wait
wait you did not answer my question you
supp
children alian kids were your child you
let the Palestinian people kill them
Palestinian people did not even kill one
single Israeli child and you killed
maybe more than 6,000 from the war of
Russia and Ukraine you killed more than
them
and so I think I responded to that point
you don't mind he doesn't mind speaking
to of the cameras but with me he doesn't
want to speak because you have nine
cameras on you but but there's nine
cameras on him too no no no
you the mic show me the mic show me the
mic show me you can't pick up his speech
you can't pick a speech anyway my
question when I said when I said I don't
want to debate
you want in the beginning I said I
didn't want to in the beginning I said
you think about killing children this
isn't going to work what do you think
about killing children in the beginning
what do you think about killing children
are you going to condemn it or are you
going to condemn killing
children are you going to condemn have
to walk away have to walk away this not
how we work no that's how we work here
no no I have to you got to give me an
opportunity speak and you keep the
aggressive and moving away my question
are you going to condemn the terrorist n
for killing children and women yes go
ahead this is this is how it works in
the beginning I said I'm not doing this
and you said no I'm just listening you
said I'm just listening I'm not debating
I'm just listening I'm listening I'm
just I'm are you question to my question
are you going to cond just listening I'm
happy are you going to cond are you
going to condemn nah who's killing the
children and the women and innocent
people if you are just listening I'm
happy for you to sit down are you going
to cond
going so you're serious supp talk how
dare you when
you walk
away everything Allah Mery him he
doesn't mind to speak here when I
challenged him for his lies and S he
wants to walk away Subhan Allah look at
these people you know so that's why you
see these people look that Zionist they
they look for innocent for like he was a
child he mentioned something which is
wrong he didn't know what he said that I
had to correct him what he want to do he
want to tell repeat again I to expose
him is I don't want to talk no cameras
so these people they want to talk about
Saddam or talking about other Muslim
leaders when they lead terrorist
murderer killing innocent people
INE look
way my question is what is about killing
children terrible that is in the Bible
go comeand killing the baby terrible of
one specific group of people no no many
times no just once I'll show you here
yeah show let me show you come
come
come I got like two minutes so let's
make it quick okay it's in yeah I know
there's one spot about Sam there a Malik
in but there's too many I show you's
more there's more you know that yeah
there's a little bit more but usually
about I'm saying there one group of
people
why God told them to kill the babies in
a moik yeah it's a Biblical Feud I talk
to God not me yeah but okay but you
human being I mean like I'm not God you
should question it God said to kill him
I haven't killed anybody in my that's
why that's why God said yeah so it's
okay to kill babies then one time no no
it's okay to kill babies no so it was
God was wrong then what God was
wrong
youh Allah spoke about them in the Quran
you know subh look at them
you know in the books said kill babies
cuz I was going to tell them about the
killing the soal Israel design is
killing children and women in in
Philistine that's what they're doing
they're pH the Bible you have to flee
quick you have to
run s